hello there guys and welcome to another
video regarding the book of boba fett so
in the last video we went over some new
details about the show if you haven't
seen that um there'll be a link in the
description anyway let's get into the
new information
so there was a couple interviews with uh
tamara morrison and robert who directed
his
entry episode in season two of the
mandalorian so morrison says
it's in the timeline of the mandalorian
so i guess we're gonna go back and see
sorry to do everything we've got ming na
when in there she's
playing the master assassin fanuc shan
we've got to look at the timeline we're
going to look at where boba has been
we've got to keep the fans happy so it
seems like there might be some time
jumping it seems like we'll see a lot of
boba
in the timeline of the mandalorian after
season two and then it sounds like we're
going to see him
in his past a little bit and because he
says he want to keep the fans happy
we're going to look at where boba's been
so i'm guessing we're going to see him
um
escape from the sarlacc pit how he
escaped from the sarlacc pit
and where he went after the sarlacc pit
what's his journey like what did he do
in tatooine
how did he get to where he was how did
he meet fanny sean so i feel like we're
gonna see that journey and then we're
going to see his
journey um in the present time in the
aftermath lauren season 2. moving on
morrison reveals the directors for the
book of boba fett so they are
robert bryce howard dave filoni and john
favreau
and i gotta say i'm really happy with
the selection here i really loved
bryce's episode in season two of the
main lauren i thought the action was
really well done and the patient was
really great and fast-paced
and i'm really happy to see that dave
filoni is yet again directing more live
action episodes i'm looking forward to
see what he has in store for us
potentially it could be like cadbane
versus boba showdown in his episode i
don't know just some speculation but
that could be pretty cool
um i gotta say i'm probably most excited
for john fravro's episode because
he's the mastermind behind everything uh
he created the mandalorian and his
episode that he directed which is really
really well directed
so um i can't wait to see what he has in
store for us for uh the book of boba
fett
anyway when morrison was asked about a
potential season two
he says i think they'll have to consider
some things the tree is still growing
they probably want to test the waters
first there's been no talk about it so
he's left a very open ended there
at the moment i think it's just a season
one with no season two in the works but
i guess
he says you know the pope want to test
the waters first so he probably means
you know we wait to see how the book of
boba fett's received if it's received
really well
then potentially there might be a second
season or maybe he's just trying to you
know keep everything open-ended and
maybe there will only be one
season i guess we'll just have to wait
and see potentially this could just
link into the mandalorian season three
anyway on to the next interview this one
was with robert
so he says boba fett he gets even
grittier than mando did i feel like he
doesn't have the choice because he
really was a different character then he
goes on to
describe boba as all killer no filler
this excites me because
i love dark star wars revenge of the
seth is my favorite star wars film um i
consider that a dark star wars film
and i feel like it really suits the
character of boba he is a dark character
and as ear robert says all killer no
phil i agree boba fett is that type of
character and it looks like we're going
to see
more of that in the book of boba fett
but anyway i know there was some
controversial
reactions to this statement so um please
let me know what you guys think in the
comment section below about
what your reaction is to um these new
interview snippets
how robert has described boba's
character do you agree do you disagree
and if you guys want to see more book of
boba fett videos or just videos on the
upcoming shows in general please leave a
like
and i'll catch you guys in the next
[Music]
video
[Music]
you